what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar in today I want to take a close
look at the story behind bond sacred
treasure the holy staff correct rose and
explain all of its unique abilities I
did a sacred treasure video in the past
where I explained all of their powers
but now we have way more information
about bond secret treasure so I wanted
to supplement that video with this one
if you enjoy seeing some daily sins
videos on this channel make sure to
smash that like button to let me know if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is very important
bring that notification bell so you
actually get notified when we publish
new videos you can always find extra
seven deadly sins content and crucial
updates on our Twitter and Instagram at
anime out drawer and you can find
exclusive original seven deadly sins
inspired merch at anime out Broadcom
shirts like Mele Otisfield or at Eskin
or praise the sun Eskin or all hail the
ones and bon love the pain if i have to
choose just one i probably say that bon
love the pain is my favorite let me know
which one's your favorite in the
comments definitely check those out if
you want to look epic and support the
channel at the same time link in the
description a quick warning there will
be manga spoilers in this video now
without further ado let's jump into it
the sacred treasures were given to the
seven deadly sins by the king of Leonys
when the group was formed bonds secret
treasures called Quattro's which was
also the name of king bonds sword in
Arthurian legend Harlequin is shocked to
find out that Meli oldest bond and the
end would allow themselves to lose their
sacred treasures that's how important
they are not only are they extremely
valuable in a monetary sense which they
are because they are all worth more than
a hundred thousand gold coins they're
even more valuable as weapons because
they can fully take advantage and
amplify the users original power in
order to illustrate this point King asks
everyone to imagine that the lake in
front of them represented the magical
powers of one of the seven deadly sins
he scoops a handful of water and says
that that is how much magic can be used
without a sacred treasure he says with a
weapon they can extract as much as a mug
and with a sacred treasure and this is
the craziest they
draw as much power as a house according
to King they could call forth an
incredible amount of magic power
compared to now if they had their sacred
treasures the difference between a
handful and the house is pretty huge so
sacred treasures are hyped up from the
beginning especially bonds bond doesn't
have his sacred treasure because he says
it was stolen when he was thrown in jail
but he agrees with Hawke that King
should stop getting bent out of shape
over weapons he appears to say that his
sacred treasure would probably make a
difference for him but for these guys
meaning malleolus and Ian they do just
fine barehanded right away bond sets
himself up as someone who would benefit
more than others from his sacred
treasure the sacred treasure is hyped up
even more because of the fact that it
takes so long to make its appearance it
is the last sacred treasure to be
introduced before in an interview 7
Deadly Sins creator naka bouzouki has
said that he likes waiting to introduce
really strong characters later on in the
story which is one of the reasons he
waited so long to introduce s Kannur
this makes sense because s Kannur would
have completely messed up the first
season by easily defeating every
opponent knockabout to wait until the
opponent's got a good deal stronger so
he could keep things interesting he
probably kept fond sacred treasure until
last for the same reason we did get a
glimpse at Kratos in episode 1 of the
anime where we were passing leash on
bond in his armor holding it but we
didn't get much else for a long time it
is a fancy for section staff connected
by chains it is not to be mistaken with
the three section plain one he uses to
fight with during other points in the
show he uses this three sectioned weapon
like nunchucks and it seems to increase
the range of his snatch ability as well
this is just a regular weapon though so
as King said it just lets him use a cup
full of power rather than a handful but
definitely not a house full of power in
fact the regular weapon has no special
abilities which is what sacred treasures
are known for it is not until chapter
315 that the final sacred treasure is
truly introduced in the manga at this
point in the manga bond was pretty much
the strongest sin besides Mele ODIs he
was the only one who could go
blow-for-blow with the demon king in
melee Otis's body long in
to help defeat him mile with sunshine
and king who had admittedly used up most
of his power
couldn't even land a shot on the demon
king the crazy power boost happened when
bond was in purgatory and he endured
over 8,000 years of being frozen burned
and poisoned his body built a huge
tolerance for damage so that even when
he lost his immortality he was stronger
than ever
it was like training in a way more
extreme version of the hyperbolic time
chamber from Dragon Ball Z thus when the
sins are fighting the Endura bond is
already one of the most powerful
characters in the series and that's when
Merle and tells bond use this with your
current capabilities you should be able
to draw an even greater power than ever
before and quote then she makes the holy
staff correos appear above him
so obviously the big question is why
didn't Marilyn give him his sacred
treasure before when he was fighting the
demon king perhaps she believed he could
handle it without the sacred treasure or
she thought it wouldn't make much of a
difference in that context since he
couldn't kill Melly Otis's body anyways
or she just forgot like when she forgot
that she was immune to the commandments
we can't be totally sure but please let
me know why you think she waited in the
comments I'd be very curious to hear
your opinion about this anyways in this
context bonds sacred treasure was
perfect there were a bunch of young
Endora
released by the big Endura they were
fighting and they needed to defeat the
countless baby endureth before they
escaped because that would lead to chaos
and destruction all around the world and
at this point we finally figure out
bonds sacred treasures unique abilities
Merlyn explains more so than any of the
other sacred treasures it's capable of
being able to freely make attacks at
irregular speeds angles and distances at
will and with bonds current strength
wielding it he should be able to
manifest absolute range speed and force
but the nail in the coffin is the power
that is able to push all of those to
their maximum level courage shows
special trait super concentration and
quote so not only does the sacred
treasure have insane power
speed and reach it also has the highest
level of accuracy thanks to its ability
super concentration by man just to kill
all of the baby in Durres but one which
is insane because they were so so many
and some made it all the way to distant
villages his move is written in the
Japanese as swath of the death God and
we are told that bond has gone far
beyond the human level thus with his
sacred treasure bond has godlike power
according to go there in an instant
thousands of Endura vanished and keep in
mind they were each strong it took mile
with sunshine to stop the one that got
away
Gil Thunder no sunshine ESCA noir and
other holy Knights were completely
powerless against just one but then the
sins turned to the big boss in Deraa
and bond uses his sacred treasure to
attack it we figure out in chapter 320
that the sins have slaved in there are
with relative ease they don't seem to
have a scratch on them and they've come
to help defeat the demon king since bond
used the sacred treasure to attack the
big boss in dura we can assume that
corey chose isn't just useful when you
have many enemies it can be just as
useful for one strong enemy keep in mind
this in dura that the demon king
summoned was not a regular in dura but
an in dura a favor
the in dura a favor we are told are
reincarnated from the 10 commandments
who were loyal and devoted to the demon
king their strength is exceedingly
massive and thus it is said their power
levels are far greater than the other in
dura
so all in dura have legendary power and
this one stands at the top of all in
dura and yet as I mentioned the sins
beated and all of its children with
relative ease mostly thanks to bond in
his sacred treasure
hence Kratos seems to easily be one of
the strongest treasures in the series
even without a bond was the only one
able to put up a good fight against the
demon king and melly Otis's body and the
treasure serves to fully dry out all of
his new power it raises his physical and
mental capabilities to their maximum
level letting him achieve a god-like
level of power
knowing naka bouzouki and how he likes
to wait to introduce strong things for
last it definitely makes sense why he
chose to introduce courage
last and it was definitely worth the
wait if bond really was able to only
draw upon a handful of power when he
fought the demon king before then I'd
love to see how much he can do with his
sacred treasure which should in theory
let him draw out all of his new power
and it's notable that we still haven't
seen him get pushed to go all-out with
the power boost
it gives him Vaughan has definitely come
a long way from being one of the weakest
sins who couldn't even protect his best
friend or love interest earlier on in
the series I would also love to see
another friendly match between Melly
Otis and bond at some point kind of how
we got to see Melly Otis in assault mode
go up against the one Eska norm
we better get that battle when all this
demon came drama comes to an end but for
the time being that is it for today's
video let me know if you want to see
videos like this one done for some of
the other sacred treasures king's sacred
treasure spirits beer chaste aful is
definitely powerful versatile and
interesting enough to justify its own
video follow us on twitter and instagram
at anime uproar so you don't miss
crucial seven deadly sins updates also
if you love the seven deadly sins and
want to support more content on this
channel at the same time you should
check out our anime inspired shirts at
anime out Broadcom there's a very wide
selection of seven deadly sins shirts
including Mele Otisfield or at esken or
praise the Sun esken or all hail the one
and bond love the pain I love these
shirts and I think they're perfect for
any Sun daily since fans so definitely
check them out at anime up road comm
link in the description a big thank you
goes out to our patrons over on patreon
who help make videos like this one
possible I especially want to thank our
pro hero tier patrons the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings eldress and angel Cruz and are the
one to your patrons the ones who stay on
top all clients baby ray a seventeen FF
DP Steven Ingrid ah a lowland autumn
Mattie Mac 239 makoto-kun and Keylong
and the patrons who transcend greatness
itself Regan Harrison and Lord naksan or
the chosen few who have been
acknowledged by Lord
go himself if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon comm anime out drawer and
becoming a patron today for as little as
one dollar if you do so you'll get your
name featured in future videos alongside
these amazing friends right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord so check out
patreon.com/crashcourse
[Music]